All right Ralph if you would please introduce yourself with your name in today's
date in our location. Okay. Ralph Coleman also Ralph Coleman, Jr. dates July 8th and
we're in my long-time residence in Eastmoreland neighborhood in Portland and
we're going to discuss OAC and the three states. Yes talk about your father and
your association with the University of Maccora-Valice as well. So let's start
with your dad and you give us a little background on his upbringing where he was born
and where he was raised. Okay sure he was born and raised in Canby which is a
suburb of Portland, South and basically a farming community. He had a small
family. He had a younger brother, two-year younger brother. His father, P.L. or
Philip Coleman had come west from Ohio and probably before the turn of the
century and had was an educator and was the superintendent of the schools there
in Canby. That's where my dad grew up when the Canby High School graduated and I
think they're very first graduating class 1914. Victoria State then OAC.
And it's not entirely clear what year he was born. Well it's pretty clear it's 1896.
There's an affidavit from his aunt who raised him and stating the birth date and so on.
Back in 1896 there was no birth certificates so the records were either kept in a family
Bible or written down someplace. But he turned up in 1900 census somehow as having been born in 1895
so he could use that. He wanted to be a year older. He used to 1895, he wanted to be a year younger
he'd used 1896. And his mother died when he was about four or five years old and
and there were the family that my grandfather had married him to sort of took the boys on and raised them.
And his primary character was his aunt Ella in Canby.
It sounds like athletics were important to him from early age.
Well I would seem so you know that in that era they probably I don't know if they played football
or anything like that but yes they had baseball team. There's a picture in these archives of him
in his uniform and with his team and played baseball for the local team. Herds arm or shoulder
or something and was not expected to ever play baseball again. So he made the decision to go to
Oregon Agricultural College in 1914. Do you know why he made that decision? I don't.
I mean they were talked about it is probably closer than the U.L.
that the decision to go to college period. The decision to go I don't know that's interesting
his brother never went and his dad had been to college but it wasn't a tradition you know the
family none of the his extended family in the Canby area I don't think it ever meant to college.
So I don't know what motivated him to do this just a smart you know ambitious kid.
People liked him he took off. He made it in dairy husbandry.
Major in dairy husbandry he got well he'd grown up in the farm community and on the farm so
this was a natural thing for him and there's pictures of him on campus with his hat and tie
and coat judging a cow or something like that. So he came out with a degree in dairy husbandry in 1918
and was immediately drafted into the army in World War I and went to Fort Lewis now Camp Lewis
the time for Lewis infantry basic you know the meat grinder route the war was climaxing in 1918
and the big offensive were going on so I needed a lot of people and he was
infantry basic applied for OCS officers candidate school excepted him to that
and that prolonged stay just long enough for the war in before they left but he was commissioned
a second lieutenant and the machine gun battalion or something like that and Maddie's due avoid
the war. Did he ever talk about his academic experience as a student?
Well I don't remember any great you know long comments about that it was primarily an agricultural
school had a technical component to it that agriculture was the main thrust and I don't know it's
that's that's a good question I don't know what it didn't hear that much about the coursework
well we normally associate him with baseball but it sounds like he's perhaps his greater talent
was in track and field that's true it was he was he even talked about this he went or he's
he'd never run at all when he never competed there had been an erase never did anything and
somehow got acquainted with some people on the track team in the cross country team and
he said come on run run with us and he ran him into the ground basically it's a natural
and so they said okay you're a come out track you know and had developed into quite a
respectable distance man his best time in the mile was in it was about 420 and I think my son is
looking up the world's record of the time was about 415 or 14 or something like that so this
was a very respectable level of achievement and there would have been an Olympics in 1918
that he probably would have you know tried for the American team and probably better pretty good shot
at it of course the water caused that to be canceled so that was the end of that but no track was his
major athletic activity at Oregon State he was captain of the track team competed in the Long Zop
and all that sort of thing so yeah that was his first that was his first athletic activity did he
ever express any regret that he couldn't have tried to be on the 11th team well maybe in passing but
you know that's the way it goes we all have good issue the wood of us you know yeah we only
played baseball for one year at Oregon made OEC yes I think that's correct he he was playing he told
me he was playing Inter-Murrow baseball you know not diversity and the and the that didn't
feel good you know injured shoulder apparently have healed up in intervening years and coach saw him
play or heard about him said you know going out and picked so he pitched some games for them in his
senior year and was pretty effective I don't think they played more than 20 games you know a season
and then later on he he was good enough to play professionally for three or four summers after
he got out of college for the Portland viewers which at the time was a AAA club and it good success good
enough to be looked at by majors and at that time a team like Portland would own the players outright
and the major leagues would buy the players from the teams they wanted if they wanted to buy
them from the team that's how the team made money he was selling their players and the majors so he
had was looked at by Detroit I think and they wouldn't have been in Oregon State he was on the staff
by that time I think he turned away from that the more secure position at OECU and professional
baseball at that the more secure position the more secure position yeah baseball in those days you
paid nothing careers were short you know there are no pensions nothing you just played for a while
and then you were gone and that was it so he you know figured he was pretty well positioned where he was
stayed on he got married getting by that time too well tell me about the OECU
little club oh I don't know very much about it just heard the name but I think that was a
the closest I can think it might have been kind of a a eating club you know they live there
and what they call co-ops might have been a co-op and sort of a semi fraternity and that morphed
into the Gamma Talk Beta while I think he was still an undergraduate when that came about
and then the Gamma Talk Beta eventually of course became double UPSLON in 1922 and that was a big
part of his you know association with the regular state well through through his living
situation he encountered a couple well a few pretty extraordinary people that he mentioned his best
friends were spec keen and double SMAK well they were close and spec was from Salem and was a good
athlete student body president and they became good friends he was the best man at my days waiting
and they were their family and our family were lifelong friends they saw a lot of each other and
spec was always around and he became athletic directors you know at the at a regular state
where he closed ties in fact his daughter lives in Kraval she'd be a good person to contact
sometime she'd be willing to you know provide information for him Doug McKay I think he might have
been a little more than an idea maybe a year so of course he would on become governor and secretary
of the interior and under eyes now so any other recollections of spec keen and double K or stories
about your father's association with them well spec was just a marvelous person and
load fishing and hunting and just all around good administrator a good guy and they did a lot
of fishing and and hunting together every summer for a number of years we all go to Nesquan
are you familiar with Nesquan it doesn't look any different you know today than I did then
or a couple of weeks and the you know eight or ten families from the Oregon State and from
Salem and various places and that was just our summer outing that was Nesquan some of the houses
we stayed in and in the mid 30s are still there looking just exactly like they did back then so
there's a lot of interaction you know a lot of closeness and in in the time maybe people still do that
I don't know how did how did Ralph meet his wife I don't know to say the truth she was a student
at Oregon State a tri-delt she grown up in Colberg and went to the University of Oregon for a while
and then transferred to Oregon State I'm not sure why she was about three years younger
like that and it was a very come-we young woman all the stories and pictures of her after a while
as well and so I don't know the details they dated and got married in there in her parents' house
in Eugene I think it was and later on they lived very firstly lived with us in Corvallis
for the better part of their lives and a very nice extended family situation
did he talk anymore about other social activities or more about fraternity life for his school years
well he tell the usual pacing stories and things like that it didn't sound all that much
different from my own experience you know 40 years later but it was I think Oregon State was a fun
place I don't think they took life all that seriously but we see in those years it was an
ag school primarily with a big military complement engineering was certainly on the picture but I
think it was mostly a local people you know local kids went there did he mention his ROTC experience
yeah he thought that was great he loved ROTC he was good at it he had a lot of kind of a command
presence and just resonated with his mentality I guess and the ROTC I think was what got him
in the OCS you know may have saved his funds if they're at Fort Lewis Camp Lewis
well I mentioned that the World War I experience kind of came in when in 1919 he returned to Corvallis
all right got out of the military in that fall as he warned in November I think he got out probably in
80 later on in the year anyway he went to boot back to Corvallis and was hired by the Corvallis
schools in their intramural or their PE athletic aspect of coaching and things like that
and you know it was no background whatever and education and I think he did that for a year
then was hired put on the staff at Oregon State in the physical education department
and they kind of tasked with developing digital programs and expanding that into the those
facilities and activities available to the whole student body he did that pretty much
resting his career he was head of intermenziner murals head of men's physical education so he
was in the PE department in 1919 and was there until 1966 so he found a home yeah
intermurals are pretty extensive these days at OCS you and what's that like
what's that like in tumurals are very extensive though I see these days and apparently we had a
ROTC on thanks for well he got them started he didn't finish it but that was what he that was his original
in fact there's a little side for you you know where the tennis courts are and it would be west of
it would be just north of the football facilities all that was the original cold and field
really yeah it was the intermural field
and that's very you know I don't know it was ever formally you know just go to call that
and then when he you know when the coaching and then he was there forever then that became
cold field no interesting little side there that's that's kind of fun
he lived at the Gamma Talbada House during this time yes and I know little about that
but like I say during the while he was when he came back after after the war and he
risked kind of reassociated with the with the fraternity in fact lived there and he didn't
wasn't in college or anything but he just moved in and that's when they assigned him this
promising but kind of socially awkward depression minus falling and my dad wasn't at school but he
was you know supposed to look out for a minus and socializing and you know getting going in school
and that's when he reported that to the house that he didn't think this guy isn't going to make it
never to stay never studies all he does is read polp westerns and sleeps a lot but so he
totally missed the mark on that one minus was so easy for Pauling that he didn't have to exert
yourself at all and as you know he was coaching or teaching undergraduate chemistry I think by the
time he was a sophomore junior so he and was a good guy I guess you know a popular guy and one of the
guys and you know think of two-time Nobel Prize winners is one of the guys normally I think he
always I think he always cherish that relationship you know because he was shy and sort of you know
I miss fit when you're that smart and that you know that level of achievement I think it's you do
I think find yourself kind of on the outside so to whatever extent it's true I think the Gamaton
beta is socialized him and would you like me to expand on that a little bit yeah absolutely okay
I I met Linus a few times we weren't close friends or anything like that but he he never forgot
a ring of state and in the Gamaton of beta it became Delt Eupselon in my team 22 national
fraternity and Linus Pauling and my dad and the number of other people were chartered members
and there's pictures somewhere in the cell of this group you know and his in 1966 it would have been
the 40-year 60s yeah I was later in that well it's in my documentation or somewhere they had a
a reunion during a anniversary might have been the 50th meeting the 60th anniversary of the
founding of the fraternity and you know all the alums in the Portland area and so on were there
and they rounded up as many of the charter members as they could find and there were about
eight or ten of them something like that and Linus's one and my dad was one and each one of them
took their turn at the myocentral stories you know about their experiences at the bed or your state
Linus was particularly funny because when they were applying to the national fraternity they
had to list the achievements and attributes and all the potential members and they wanted to have
you know some athletic experiences for everybody you know he played this he did that Linus had no
athletic you know background whatever so my dad was assigned the chore of teaching him to run
hurdles so they could claim he was a track man and Linus described you know and there's a very
funny way is he and my dad bounding around the track you know or Travallis jumping over
over hurdles so he could claim to be a hergler so he had a Linus that a good sense of humor and he
told some interesting stories he told about he talked for about 45 minutes just unscripted and I
just I'd give anything to him had a a recording of that because he talked about his his experiences
with passports and beaches and he was on his way to Stockholm to get one of his Nobel prizes
and they landed in Oslo and nobody met him nobody from the embassy came to greet the plane or anything
he was he was you know not a good repute at the time and so he went on to Stockholm on his own and then he
he was also given the prize he got from the award he got from Russia the Lennon Peace Prize
Lennon Peace Prize okay and so he had been awarded the Lennon Peace Prize and was you know
requested to go to Russia and receiving he couldn't get a visa and just couldn't get permission
from Russia to enter Russia here he is gonna get the Lennon Peace Prize they wouldn't have
any money in the country so he contacted one of his science colleagues in Russia and say you know
what the hell's going on here I'll come I can't come they won't let me come so the guys did not
look and do they got back to me said well they got two the Linus Pauling files yeah one is Linus Paul
and you know peace loving advocate the world peace and so on the other is Linus Pauling
capitalist running dog this one somehow the application got in the comments of
capitalist running dog file so they wouldn't grant it they got a straight down but I thought
that was you know it's kind of a typical cold war snafu you know they weren't they weren't on
the same page anymore the rest of us were so anyway he got there and got the Lennon
prize and of course this was a controversial event you know was when was that the 60s yeah 60s
out 70s maybe yeah cold war and that didn't go down well and because he was being criticized for
you know his nuclear test band proposals and atmospheric testing so on so he was he was
controversial enough that it was and I was student at the U of O was a grad student later he came
through on some kind of a speaking thing and and it was controversial this would have been the
60s late 50s yeah late 50s and in fact he was a little aside stories kind of interesting you know
in our life of Trinity there's a picture of Linus hanging in the Dan and you know for other
dignitaries and this would have been in the early 50s and his picture was taken down by some
of the members hidden away somewhere it just disappeared because of this you know it's the attack
from the the right and yeah I don't think it phased Linus at all I think he just plowed on through
you know I don't know so he you know he knew he wanted to do he did his you know everlasting credit
and he and your dad maintained a connection over the years or he and your dad maintain a
connection uh loose loose connection I don't think it was ever you know there was a uh history
there at early days which you know you don't you remember those things but I don't think there was
much you know correspondence or much contact because he was you know operating in a entirely different
different level yeah well back to your dad in the early days in Corvallis he coached
freshman track for four years too uh I think that's right I don't have all of that during his
own and some of those uh information I gave him I think that was probably his first coaching job
was uh was track did he maintain an interest in track over the years yes he did yeah he uh he
loved he loved helping with track needs and uh helping put them on ice school track needs so he was
yeah that was his first athletic love I think he's also an outstanding golfer
hmm yeah we became the head baseball coach there in the 1920s but it was a different situation
back then that is now how do you mean well he's essentially a volunteer job for one oh right
right right I'm not sure it was a big job I think he often often said that it was not he was paid
you know to be an administrator teacher in the physical education department and academic
point up there so baseball was just sort of an aside it wasn't a very uh I don't think high-powered
program there's photos in this thing it's show the baseball field in 1920 there isn't even a backstop
you know walled walls there and you see the egg building and the heating plant with the
chimney and all that but nothing else is around there so it was very you know low-key operation
and uh he uh he didn't want to be paid for it largely because he said that uh didn't there be an
expectation you know he didn't want that he wanted to be able to do this as uh as a hobby you know
that's a fun thing and it was and uh got him a lot of notoriety you know made him a lot of
friends and a lot of fun for him but he didn't want the they eventually didn't start paying him
you know years later but it was not a big and big amount of money that wasn't his job that wasn't
how he made his living and I always thought that was kind of shrewd you know uh coaches get fired
because they don't perform and uh he didn't want that you know get find somebody if you get
somebody for the price you're getting me for go for it yeah but he didn't coach non-stop from 1922
on he ever several periods there when he was had other administrators uh do these in the 30s
slash guild coach I think for about six years yeah that was fascinating to discover a
slash guild also baseball catch yeah but it was a very low key sport uh like I say 20 games maybe
if they were lucky and they just played local teams was there any recruiting at all or I don't
know or my dad recruited he would recruit locally scout around high school kids in the summer
so nothing like nothing like today light years you know are there any scholars that he saw for
back then uh I think by the time I got there in the 50s I think there were some there were some
scholarships they'd have a handful it split up into little pieces most I think they were you
had to work for them in those days if you were getting a a stipend ride they call it years you
had to put in a certain number of hours you know cutting grass or doing something and you know
they made us they we had to do that well tell me about how his his coaching career evolved over time
I mean the baseball became more formal and he became more established the program became more established
well it was just an evolution I don't know if they uh they were long time rivalries or some great
pictures of one picture in their book Bailey kicking the bucket you know water spraying out
and so they were and Oregon they were you know lots of good rivalries there and uh people like the
game uh but it just developed and got you know and they're beginning the northern division was there
and then eventually in the 50s late 40s they formed a it was the southern division the California
schools rise there we didn't play them and then in that era they started to play postseason
games the college world series came along and by 1946 or 47 something like that
storage W Bush was captain of the first Harvard team I think they won the college world series
it was the first baseball George H. W. Bush first first first H. W. Yeah not W. H. W.
great so uh college baseball got a big shot in the arm when that national competition started
and they had good years and bad and uh it was a lot of fun at any point did he feel like that he
was baseball coach was his job and and the other job was less of his job or well yeah I don't think
so you always pay attention to where you're who signs the check and uh but baseball was what uh
you know got in his reputation and then his social thing and uh you know his players loved him and
everybody knew who he was and he's a very personable guy and I mean people responded to him and
liked him and so that makes life easy yeah it's only more about his personality you see he was an
intense competitor he said oh yes yes yes yes he just on the bench he was just a constant motion
you know throwing grass in the air and stilting up and down attacking the young players and
challenging calls you don't see that anymore at all you know but all the coaches used to do it back
you know in the 40s and 50s and 60s and uh and uh but after the game was over no problem he's
you know everything was fine but I think I think that was uh I was kind of a negative I mean your
coach is just constantly you know spinning out of control practically and your sports remain calm
and in control but uh you know his his intensity was infectious or question about it and you
want to win too well uh obviously Corvallis is in a rainy place and and baseball is played during the
spring when it's often rainy and wet do you never did he have a facilities component to his job too
I'm sorry what a taking care of the field you know obviously well that's yeah the players did
most of that because they were on a scholarship or ride and then we did a lot of that so you
can imagine what kind of shape that baseball field is in uh we used the armory for our spring
you know workouts and things and the season didn't start we didn't play any games until the start
of spring quarter now it's you know they played what 60 or 70 games a year now yeah we were lucky
if we played 25 or 30 and that was fine with me it's good to get the season over who want to do
other things well let's travel like back then no buses cars we took uh my senior year I guess it
was we took our first out of state trip spring break there's a week in there and so my dad
is scheduled to several games in California so we piloted these cars and took off for
California and played Stanford, Cal and Sacramento and Fresno and you know and we didn't have any
budget at all this was the first out of state trip you know except for the conference play the
first you know they do this routinely now they go all over the country you know playing in turn
of months and this was an interesting experience the I think it would have been 1953 probably
and we'd pull into some town like uh oh Berkeley we'll play Cal and my dad is say okay
the game we have to feel tomorrow at noon games at 2 30 or something be there to see yeah we were on our own
we never hotel we didn't have anything we I think we had some meal money I think you might have
given us some meal money but um and we were supposed to fend for ourselves we did by staying
in fraternities you know you know I fall in and call it the U House and say you know I'm down
here with the Oregon State baseball team and we come and camp there for a couple days oh sure
and also with the guys that weren't in fraternities we just bring them along you know pretend like they
were so that's how we got by in Fresno we finally stayed in the hotel because I think he wanted
to know where everybody was when they came time to go home but other than that we were just uh
just freelancing it that's I can't compare that to the day they have everything but they're private jet you know
how did the how did the colonel feel itself it wasn't called colonel feel them and how did
it change over time well I think you just got just fell into the usage you know uh
I uh before it was dedicated you know formally dedicated yeah uh just
did he have to raise some funds do you do you recall to have improvements made or
I don't recall anything like that I think it was just uh based on what the what the athletic
department would provide potentially they put a backstop up they put a backstop up yeah we had
we had seats bleachers and all that kind of thing but it was uh it was pretty primitive there
were no fence out in the outfield oh really no and uh and the ground was hard and
while we got past the outfielders it was all run but you couldn't hit one out of the park they were
all inside the park oh yeah so that was a meter interesting you know addition to the to the
challenges so you wanted fast outfielders yeah you mentioned the training was pretty casual
yeah yeah there what really wasn't any you know we just started we'd work out the gym or the
armory and my dad's dress running because that was especially for pictures because that was
you know good for you but uh no you know half the team probably smoked including my dad and uh
that was just you know we take smoke breaks during the game under the stands I love the buses
and things like that so a little more casual yeah and this is both teams with a giant for the
smoke break right well yeah I guess I haven't thought of that but we were on the first base side in
those days now they're on the third base side and uh down up the south end of the field they
knew the wooden football stadium stands that went around there I don't know if you think of
that yeah they'll feel there was we go down under there and then stand so you know be out of the
yet sides it wasn't it was this was a schedule before the game where it says some signal when
out there was time for a smoke break in between getting you know well his most successful team was
probably 1952 the team that won the PCC championship in the Western Regional which of the call
at the World Series in Omaha you were you're a member of the squad anyway right I was a member of
the squad it was actually Jay I was JVing at that year didn't play uh you know played against the
varsity and with them and practice in practice and things like that but no I didn't I didn't actually
played with the team and the numbers they took back to Omaha I think they were restricted so again it
was a fairly small squad there were players that played you know a lot of part of the season that
didn't didn't go back they got hammered they lost the first two games it was hot and so on but they
got there that was amazing didn't make it back for another what 30 years or 35 years or something
like that well do you remember much about that that season I mean it sounds like it was sort of
magical season well things came together and some really good athletes uh those days
it was uh very common for if for guys to play more than one sport and uh let me see our
catcher was a starting end with the first baseman was a starting forward second baseman was a
starting guard the basketball team the third baseman was a linebacker football linebacker left
fielder was another tight end and so I think out of if you took away the pitchers I think there were
three starters on that team that didn't start for some other team so without those guys we
have been helpless you know so yeah you could play and they love that they love baseball because I
got them out of spring football and that sort of thing so they're all wonderfully baseball
and it was a fun sport what do you remember hearing about the the Omaha trip obviously didn't go
all the field but it was well I think they went by train long train the very hot while they were
there um Omaha you know in the at time of year it could be pretty pretty bad and uh I don't think
their accommodations were very good is it I think it was only about the if you've fifth or sixth year
of the college real series so I don't think they really gotten their rhythm down yet and uh
there I remember them talking about the heat they couldn't sleep and we had these heavy wool uniforms
just one uniform you want something warm as you played out here but back there it just was totally
you know inappropriate I think that hurt them you remember it being a big deal with they had made
the world series on campus oh yeah yeah we played the we played USC uh so the Cal we were the
Perennial champions and we played them in in play them in Kerala so we played them in Los Angeles
the year before they beat us down there we got them again in Kerala so 52 and I think we had
5,000 people there they put the stands up you know drag them in from all over and huge crowd
it was a big deal yeah that must have meant something else it was great fight
um a couple of no warry players that I came across maybe you can comment on do you know
much about West Schoenrich yeah I knew West um he was uh lived over in the coast I think uh
over on the Ness Tucka and it was a fishing guide and an outdoor type of guy and he'd come to all
the games big burly you know voice through this guy and uh it was also a great football player
I don't know if he played in the pros or not but he was he did play pro baseball he did play
major league baseball for the Philly sand another name I came across was Ed Coleman it called
them right yeah his half brother it was several years younger and played for the warry state and
really good career in the majors he played about five or six years and uh they played for
the Portland Beavers after that he was uh he had a good career he's in uh he was in the record
books for a while he was a great pinch hitter he'll the American league pinch hit season single
season pinch hit record for about 30 years or something so he had a good success athletic family yeah
did you don't have a particular styles of coach and any sort of philosophy of baseball I mean
we pat kc is famous for a small ball approach was there anything like that
uh just beat the other guys up you know that 52 team was a good he was the guy for huge you know
the starting four were just six five and uh football players were six three six four for the day
these guys were huge it's big pitchers and everything physically and uh we would make sure that
when we take batting practice before a game that was always pretty game rituals since each team
take batting practice you watch the other team you know hit and we make sure that the bigger the bigger the
bigger the guys were this earlier they got out and hit so we dropped these great big guys out you know
and uh they'd be in the ball all over the place and it was intimidating you know so yeah he
liked that kind of a team you know so he didn't we didn't play much small ball I think the idea was just the
you know overpower yeah who are some of your dad's best friends in corralis well he was there for
a very long time as you say is a popular guy the only belong to all the clubs along the yorks club
and the rotary club and you know if there was a club he'd join it and uh most of the close friends
we had there were a lot of them in the department the land teams dixons other coaches
slaskyo you know we just uh line Steiner the role close friends the absolutely the coaches
and he had close friends just among the townspeople he was a small town boy and uh and uh liked
you know the small town associations what was your impression of slaskyo uh terrific guy I like
slats a lot I used to cady for him and he'd always give me two bucks I think that was uh
so and he had two kids who were a little younger than me but of course we I knew them and
everything slas was a really good guy he just you know found his niche and stayed in it
and just you know did great and uh they'd be on they'd be you know standard participants in the annual
beach trips and the parties and and hunting and fishing and they they did all this stuff you know
all the coaches and uh people did all these things together no slasks was uh uh
you know really uh really a good guy
trying to think there was something else I was going to say about him like I remember what it was
oh maybe a little anecdote you may not know uh UCLA uh was looking for a basketball coach
and they ended up hiring John Wooden but uh slasstered it down
his teams had beaten them UCLA two years in a row over the championship so
uh he'd be decided to he'd come out with us I don't think they'd get off or any kind of money
but he used to say to stay out he grew up in Salem so he was a young very much a local
local boy so Wooden went on to become you know a legend and uh but slats preferred the smaller arena
uh how about Lon Stiner and did you know him all oh yeah yeah Lonnie was just a really nice guy
he was lots of fun and we go hunting and fishing you know my dad and Lonnie and uh and he just he liked
he was he you know when you're a kid you know when there's people growing up so like you and
others that are just kind of going to the motions you know and Lonnie really liked uh like
people like kids this is the terrific guy well it sounds like outdoors were important to this group
of men were there are hangouts that they they frequented besides the lodges
the Welsh club primarily that was the place where everybody gathered and it was right in the center
of town at the time uh they didn't know if the building is still there but it was right you know on
third street or fourth street and so this was just the focus for all uh social activities in
town that moose and others but the else club was the one that most people you know frequently
my sense of the athletic department during your dad's time is of a pretty tight net group
that accurate you think yeah I think so yeah Paul Dundee of course he came in in late 30s
played basketball and then navy and then came back and never left he still went right
I think his name is in the ball school he was the J.B. baseball coach was he not he was he was the
freshman he was the only assistant my dad had and I don't think he got paid but he was the tennis
coach system basketball coach and the system baseball coach so he was your coach is the J.B.
right right what was he like as a coach oh good guy you know baseball hadn't been his game but
it mattered you know he could manage it and then we played a game against the uh as a freshman
they had freshman teams in those days it only played three years of RC so you played your first
year as a freshman and we went over played the penitentiary you know in Salem they played a hole
the zang was that they played a strictly home schedule so we were in there and it was fun you
know the let us in that there had been the penitentiary and you know the field was out in the corner
it was huge wall and the umpire was uh I was pitching the game actually and the umpire was
you know the convict and and so on and they were just on each other totally they'd bother us you
know but they were just razzing each other everybody had a nickname and so it was a it was a fun
experience uh I don't know the baseball I don't know if the prison grades I don't know if they still
have a baseball team or not we dad was also an official you fished at football and basketball
yes yeah and that was his it was a hobby I mean made money at it and uh yeah and quite a good
reputation he he was uh uh football official with several Rose Bowls and uh and yes that's
why he finally got out of that in the late 30s it was two more to physically demand me you know
the football and the basketball no he did a lot of many was um kind of commissioner for referees
for a while for the conference he would evaluate officials and rate them and the other things
they're overseer well he retired in 1966 and he mentioned he was a good golfer at C-Sing to
have turned his attention to golf at that well he always played golf like I'll take that back
he's I don't know when he started playing golf but uh he helped lay out the Dallas Country Club
really and uh it was really good and coached your taught golf you know your coach's golf when he
taught golf for years in physical education department or in state and uh played it a lot
and was good anything like that came easy to it you know when your athletic attempts to generalize
all areas and uh do you play golf uh a little bit do you know what a shank is
yeah well he developed the shanks the terminal case of the shanks and uh he uh didn't play for
about 15 years just walked away from the game totally he was a regular golfer you know a
couple times a week kind of thing and took the lessons and tried everything and uh this couldn't
couldn't get over it and then when he retired he kind of got him back into golf a little bit
when he retired they left Krovalis my mother and sold their house and moved to Woodburn
a senior stage and he was hired there as the golf to take over the golf program so yeah that was his
retirement venue yeah golf is important to him he liked that game again he was so competitive that
it's kind of you know you can't be overly good you can't try too hard you know and go off as a game
you have to play below your you know your maximum effort yeah and so I think that that was uh
kind of uh made it harder do you know anything more about the the laying out the country club
I mean just didn't that story uh only that uh they planted all those uh they planted fur trees
laid out the course I don't know what it was with the then the members and the volunteer
the volunteer and they planted all those fur trees in the rough and it was only nine holes
you know begin with and uh very yellowy and clay and it's just like concrete you know to play it so
that was laid out in uh probably mid-twenties so he was a charter member then I think probably was yeah
probably pretty close um well Colmanfield is dedicated as such in April 1981 I'm sure that meant
something to him you do you have memories of that particular moment that that event yeah my
older son and I went down and um and were there there's pictures and documentation
you know in the material that this there and uh Robert McVicker was the president and uh Jack
Riley was the coach and it was during I think it was secondary to a game I can't remember exactly
I think it was very nice event and then the speed she was a very good presenter
and um could tell jokes there's I think uh I don't think it's any record of what he said at that
event but there's some other information there's some he would write it out ahead of time so there's
some things in there he said but he could uh he was good good on his feet do you think I meant
though I tell him that the field had been named after him officially oh I think so yeah we wouldn't
you know that was uh that was a source of pride and she uh nice honor for him and after that it
sounds like he got another job in baseball the Portland Marrow's I think are you familiar with the
history of the Portland Marrow's okay well he uh big Russell who was an actor western actor
the Portland Beaver franchise and then kind of left bacon he picked this up for practically nothing
I think it was partly due for light of venue for Kurt his son Kurt Russell to play who was quite
a active baseball player and the Mavericks were independent the own team they were owned by any other
majorly team or anything like that and these were just free agents some pros some amateurs and uh
being Russell hired somebody to manage the team and he would be around these players up
and they played and they uh it wasn't AAA it was uh I mean a double A level down Mama City
and I think there's a movie being made about you know books for things like that and uh they were a
very flamboyant you know bunch and uh and uh when at one point Frank Peters then he was an
Oregon State baseball player basketball player played on that final four basketball team
and it played professional baseball and he was hired as the manager
and uh he hired my dad to be his third base coach because he played for my dad and so
there's a Mavericks hat around the house somewhere so he spent two or three seasons you know
helping you know manage the four Mavericks that was later on we were pretty late in his life right yeah
okay so let's turn the attention to you now um you were born and raised in Corvallis and
I just didn't know the Corvallis that you knew growing up as a boy small town all the way
everything just revolved around the campus summertime everything just quit everybody just
tanned at their yards and laid around and you know they didn't have much in the way of summer school
oh they did have a summer school and one of my dads the assignments was to work with the summer
students and setting up field trips they go to you know uh the bodybuild dam with Timberline
Modge and over the coast and he organized he just loved this kind of thing you know and so but it was
uh it was a nice place to be in the summer very little was going on and uh the the Corvallis calendar
was Oregon State's calendar you know the New Year's Day was when schools started in the fall
like it wasn't in wasn't in January because everything just focused on the activities on campus and
most everybody you know worked for the camp college one you know directly you're indirectly
and it wasn't an excuse for Corvallis being there but I haven't been for Oregon State so
and it was it was uh it was a very nice uh place to grow up
campus was our playground uh the kids you know we just we knew how to get into every building and uh
in the everything you know we needed to get into and uh our parents didn't know what we were doing
I don't think they wanted to know what we were doing but so it was a it was a playground
as you got a little bit older and to say the high school age were were the places that the kids
congregated you mean him Corvallis yeah well there was some there was some uh there was some
drive-ins and there was a drive-in theater up between Albany and Corvallis there was a fun place to be
there were places downtown restaurants I don't remember having any particular it was kind of like
American graffiti did you see remember American graffiti and that was a lot like Corvallis was a lot
like the American graffiti you know ambiance very nice place to grow up and everybody kind of had their
their their activities you know everybody garden their mothers all collected antiques and
blade bridge and most of the mothers didn't work faculty wives there weren't jobs first of all who
wasn't uh I don't think it was considered uh quite socially acceptable for mothers to be working
it was kind of kind of an admission that you needed the money you know what I mean
so there everybody had lots of time there wasn't much there weren't very many organized activities
you know we kids we just did what we wanted to do and say well the home for dinner you know when
that was it so what sort of impact do you remember the depression having on the town it sounds
like the the faculty refer little on the economic impact but well that that was my impression you
know I didn't I wasn't you hardly aware of the depression it was just the way things were
that I was born in 1931 of course that's just when it was in its worst and it didn't affect the
university college that met much everybody I don't think they had much of the way of cutbacks
I think although I can't couldn't document it there were times when they did not get paid at all
but the state they were given IOUs and I think they were honored later on but that was it was
it kept breathing and of course there were migrants in Krabalus and I show up at our back door
and want food and that sort of thing so it was it was there and of course World War II came along
and ended that and I heard well that's my next question is well how did this how did the town
respond to World War II what was it like during that period of time well of course the
there were no men around they had a a a STP programs anything to it was an army sponsored
program for soldiers to go to college and I think they became officers at the end of it so there's
an STP program but these are soldiers essentially assigned to that role and as far as men went on
campus that was about yet the women lived in the fraternity houses and the school kept going but
you know the war was having a big impact on it was a dare and the midst of its
yes it was yes the camp of dare was had a huge impact on Krabalus and Albany and it
you know it was a basic well you know of camp of dare was for basic infantry infantry basic
training I think they put forward divisions infantry divisions through their three or four
years it was right and that's a lot of soldiers and we had we had one living in our house we always
had one living in our house with us not but they get back we didn't have soldier living there we had
his wife living there in our spare bedroom and this was pretty typical the wives would follow the
the soldiers out to be around through their basic training and these guys would get released from
you know camp of dare for a weekend or something and hear them clump up the stairs at night you know
GI boots and down the next morning and so that was pretty standard too so the city was you know
supporting that effort my mother was a great lady that's kind of a nurses auxiliary
volunteer at a hospital at Campodare and and they were at uniforms they worked in the military
or anything but they would write letters for soldiers and keep them company in the hospital
so she did that during the whole war this is a volunteer we were able to go out there and all
of that off limits I don't remember going on the base during the war afterwards again once the war
was over why did I think that back we didn't go out there because we were in the gym doing something oh
I know yeah my dad had during what the construction of it they had a baseball league or softball one
two and my dad coached one of those teams the construction teams and so I was on the camp of
dare a couple times and one time we were in the gym I guess it would be and there was a whole slug of
POWs in there we were storing POWs at Campodare during the war and these were African Corps
guys Germans and by the way they were a tough looking bunch and then there were also Italians
around and they were so you know they were more open and friendly and stuff so they were being
housed there I don't know if they ever escaped or not but they didn't look like the security was
very tight they had a pretty well pretty good as it was that's interesting I hadn't known about that
the expansive of it there is amazing when you see it now the expansive of it there is it was
amazing when you see it now it's quite and it's there's not a lot there it was used to be the
second biggest honor in Oregon it was huge covered maps they had a artillery range the camp
of dare a lot of it egregious for an artillery range and we get you're blooming away over there
you mentioned in your memoir that the family traveled to San Francisco for the world's fair in 1939
you remember that at all oh yeah that was a great outing we stayed with my great aunt
lived in San Francisco and yeah that was a nice nice event
you taste your own a lot of artifacts from that
well tell me about high school in Corvall's high school you were the senior class president
I wasn't indeed and had a lot of fun in high school you know
I did not a lot of people don't have good experiences in high school but I had good experiences
you know everything wasn't a hundred percent but you know I was on the baseball team and the golf team
and you know had good friends and had a nice time we won the state high school basketball
championship I was in junior I wasn't on the team but that doesn't get any better than that when
in high school you know to have the win the state basketball championship
we made the decision to go to Oregon State College it sounds like there was there wasn't
much of a decision I mean no that was kind of dead that was you know I can't think of anybody in
my class high school graduate class that did go anywhere else you know initially and there
was a lot of faculty kids in Corvall's obviously so they were going to go to college but that was
closest one and the most affordable so that's kind of what we all ended up
what was it like playing in your dad's baseball program
fine had a great had a great time and it was you know no stress everybody accepted it and had a good time
yeah that seems to be the real honor you know for me yeah
you played summer baseball yeah that's what everybody did in those days
there was on the baseball team because the you know my dad we want we want to be playing and he
want you know he's he's players be playing too and we'd be hired we'd be sent out these small
towns every town had a baseball team a semi pro baseball team which means semi pro means professionals
ex-professionals could play on the team back in those days that was a no-no in terms of
amateur status who were supposed to play with pros but they made an exception for baseball so
these town teams that have some ex pros and some college guys and some locals and uh
he was a big deal for the town and they get his jobs you know we're going to the woods or
pulling on the green chain or something like that and it was about what was out there
in the mill pond job I was not that was not uh I was living in Corvall's that summer and they gave
me a big you know that was a summer we went to uh Air Force basically or not anyway uh that was a
mill south of Monroe you know Monroe is and had big mill pond and yeah that was a that was a
dangerous job and a tough one will tell some more about what that job until well uh every saw
mill had a mill pond where they would store logs and uh and you would the logs will be brought up
to the uh where there was a conveyor belt and then we then lifted and uh conveying into the
sawmill and cutting the boards and uh people have moved the logs around we're called pound
pond monkeys and you're out there in your court boots and you're big pole and all with
and uh trying to corral these logs and uh you know push it across the pond and get them over to the
where they could be picked up and they're about five of us and the pond monkeys and none of us knew
what we were doing and they dumped the logs and one end of the pond of log trucks and then we
gathered up five or six of these or gave them a raft and propelled across the across the pond
and then uh haven't lifted up there were a couple of uh professional pond monkeys there they
were just split around you know and uh fly across the logs and we were in the water half the time
interesting experience and this terrible water you know like I said my mother wouldn't let me
even the house you know and come over you smell some bad yeah so that's what we did that was those
the jobs are available minimum wage no unions you know so you're just totally the mercy of the
you know owner but there you guys that was you know that was a career for a lot of people
for us at least it was just a summer experience and so it was a great incentive to uh believe me
you know to stay in college and find something better because that's where a lot of these guys
spend their lives you know pulling on the green chain and this sort of thing probably that's
some interesting characters I'm sure yeah and then that was spent summers in coquillo and Brookings
doing that those sorts of jobs played for their town team some rough and tumble towns they were
indeed cowboys and Indians and fishermen and loggers and you were ahead he spent that summer in
primal too right primal I see coquillo Brookings and primal those are my three stops yeah
well you know to tell two Slot too I was yeah I was a legacy and uh looked at other houses but
they had a nice combination I thought of athletes and scholars and weest rules you know
didn't take themselves too seriously that were you know a good bunch of guys and uh so I never
had regrets about that that worked out pretty well nice nice group um you mentioned that
a particular fraternity I don't know if practice the right word for it but there's a story
involving skimmers view in Oregon yeah you just said Oregon no they had a we had a genius for
they're coming up with stuff like that uh no that's a true story and uh when I was a freshman
my freshman class I didn't have to go on that but they went down and blew a piece of it off they
didn't get the whole thing but they did die in my some of it off you know skimmers do never get caught
made it back and uh two years later went back and really you know got the whole thing this time and
it was uh it uh they also got the way with that you know the FBI was interviewing everybody on campus
and I'll try to get a handle on who his dynamite was considered you know a dangerous substance
and they steal it from the stump blasting class during the state you know the egg school and
some basketball class so these guys steal dynamite the caps nutty you know just nutty but uh
it uh they never caught out he did it this is the big oh that's the big oh and it's a big
concrete oh and then then the uh the guys that didn't went back later and they'd gather up pieces
chunks of it and everybody had it in the house had a chunk of this oh when they're on their
desk the paint don't know it was about that thick you know I mean paint is we we we were back in
the calmer days you know or you state would be down in painted orange and then or you get to get
the next day and paint it yellow so that it happened a lot but I think that was the last time that
you ever got uh you never got blown up the last time I never but here's the little interesting
side story I was not at a game in Watson one time years and years later and uh and I was
relating this story you know about my fraternity being a dynamite of the old uh
skater being a guy behind me he says came around he says is that a true story did you you know
you read the guys that did that and I said yeah and he said I wrote my master's thesis on that
on the time of the old so it was a story that you know had legs at least
well what was social life like for you in school uh rich no very good or you state was a nice
friendly place and there were too many men and not enough women you know student body it was
mostly you know egg school the engineering school and all that so men out the women but uh
it was good you had a lot of fun it was uh if you lived on campus with most of us did
you lived in our fraternities you were not like a different universe you know your parents were
glad to have you out of the house and you were glad to be out of the house and you might as well be
in Chicago you know the amount of interaction at this place just wasn't any yeah what sorts of
events were important on the social calendar all house dances you know I said one major
every house that had one major house dance every quarter and those were big events and uh
you know if you were dating somebody you'd get invited to her house dance and she invited you to
invite her yours and so on so there's a lot of that and a lot of beer drinking at a
Murphy's Beach and Murphy's Beach is you know South of town there's a tabern we've got about
two or three miles out of town on the right hand side and a whole Murphy's. Yes go Murphy's okay
well just pass that half a mile there's a road that goes off to the east
off of the highway down to the river and I think there's I don't know what's down there now but
back then it was a gravel operation and this is where all the parry took place because
it's called a birth speech and nothing to do with the tabern what that was where everybody gathered
it's a new one of me that's a new one for me oh yeah that was that was the place and you know
if anybody wanted to do a you know a rest of the Sir Haslis raining we everybody knew where we were
and it wasn't just my fraternity everybody was out there you know the football team the basketball
team everybody you know so a lot of party going on I don't think nothing has changed I don't think
we played baseball in the springs and springs in the summer did you do anything in the fall
or winter to get ready for the season or is it just being a whole student I think once the season was
over we were done I don't remember any particular each each season you know each football
football season basketball season baseball season they had a start to stop time and you know we
have guys that played three sports and throwing a state three major sports and started each
year every team so you can do that then and I don't think that's can they do that now I don't think so can
I think very few do if they could yeah
now how about school how about what was your academic experience like I was a moderate success modest
success I was in business administration and that wasn't a very stimulating major for me and but
you know I made my grades and I was only on probation once that's not too bad for four and a half
years so but I graduated any teachers about the main impact on you pardon any teachers you know
Gordon Gilkey Gordon Gilkey he was a good teacher
you know this is a long time ago can you tell me more about him I'm interested in Gilkey well Gordon
you know had he'd been in Europe during the Second World War and had one of those people that
participated in saving the you know uncovering the German stashes of art and so on and really made
a major contribution there and then he was a also a woodblock print collector and huge
Japanese woodblock collection and taught the course course surveyed visual arts or something anyway
it was a review of you know art and history and so on fascinating course and he taught that every
year and then later on he became Dean I think the liberal arts and I think so and he lived right
around the corner every retired or he stayed he's a good guy his son was there his son was a
photographer yeah yeah I'm asking a little bit about the climate on campus during the time you were
there you were there towards the end I think of the large influx of GI Bill students you're
mentioned in your memoir they were somewhat aloof oh yeah and I'm guessing that you have a
sense of why from your own military experience but can you talk a little bit about the GI
influence on campus why were there what was huge you know first there was a huge number of them
and then a lot of them married they're older these guys you know they weren't interested in
mourning booklets or any of that stuff that just went by the boards you know they weren't having any
of it you know these wanted to get in there and get their education and get on with their lives
and so that changed the whole campus tenor you know totally and then here along came my group you
went into the high school graduates and never you know you know you didn't want to do anything
and they all the upper the upper two classes in the fraternity house were all over two guys
and they ran the these they ran these fraternities like boot camps the the guy down the hall for me
one of the seniors I think it's a senior that by that time he bought a Kyle he then wound in the
battle of the bulge you know he didn't mess around with those guys you know and they didn't take any
you know very serious very business like and they were good role models you know we learned from
those guys so yeah they changed the whole campus philosophy has turned it upside down and then
they were I started in 1949 so they were kind of a tail end of it and ones that came along after
me not of us had ever been in the military so some occasionally where the Korean War came along
and that changed a lot a lot of things we had a lot of Korean War veterans around so that the
workloads tradition die out at that point I mean that was very strong before then what's that
the workloads and things like that that sees to me yeah that just sort of I think people tried to
get it back in place but if I don't think it everybody it wasn't the same as it had been
and things were changing anyway you know it wasn't just the World War II events the whole world had
changed you know the Second World War just changed everything old majors didn't matter anymore you know
and new technology was coming on and so the very revolutionary in retrospect you know very
revolutionary period well and you mentioned that some I'm trying to ask about the
subject of race and especially the example of the man who you write about in your book it is
not a revolution on campus funny stretch but it's an inkling of a very gradual change that's
going up going to come later in terms of the the topic of race it always you well or you say
it was a pretty pretty one race institution at the time we had we had black students from Africa
exchange students and Asians of course have been around for a long time so it wasn't totally
white but it was predominantly and there are no black athletes Oregon it had black athletes in the
30s football players Jackie Robinson's old brother Mac was a track man at Oregon and so Oregon
State was you know late to the game and Dave Mann was recruited out of California to come and
the Oregon State's first black athlete which he was and it was very successful and I didn't know
him very well personally but he was he was he stood out on question about it and he was he was not a
what would you call he was not a self-refacing person that a good way to put it but not a bad person
I mean he didn't cause any problems or anything he just he was new to you know this was a new
thing Oregon State and the Corvallus confident day yeah very confident a good athlete didn't take any
stuff you know you want a campus boxing tournament it was a passing idea there was a campus box
in tournament yeah it was well it was yeah it's a mural and yeah they just three three about three
roundabouts yeah he won that was this is a period of time where there were many concert hats on campus
still were and what was that like did you have did you have classes in them or you know I don't
remember having I think they're mostly used for office space meeting rooms and things like that
they weren't big enough for you for a classroom such as reflective of a period of expansion on
campus influx of new students yeah I want to ask you about a couple things that happened at
at OSC during your time of 1950 Gil Carl C. Muppent remember do you remember that
well I don't remember having any major event that you know it had been coming for a long time it
just didn't magically appear you know everybody knew it was it was coming it was yeah it was a big event it
was the state of the art at the time you know that was the Oregon State athletic facilities were first
class Parker Field was new Oregon had riggedy wooden stands still when California schools had big
stadiums but you know Oregon State specialties were pretty good spec key was responsible for most of
that really do you have recollections of attending basketball games in the old men's gym yes I did
saw Slantfield's teams not going to UCLA twice in a row yeah get pulled to help 2,000 people
there was a balcony that ran all the way around the men's gym and you know the two
so yeah you know I start going there when I was probably four or five years old
it must have been quite an environment it was just athletics all the way you know how about football at
Bell Field well it was a mud bowl so it was you know and you were close to the field but the
student section was on the west side and in those days if you can believe it the co-wits all were
heels and stockings and pants dressed up for the game imagine that yeah that's amazing
well we sort of wind up here a little bit I'm interested in knowing about your continued
association with OSU after you graduated you obviously had a career in the military you
went on to other things and graduate studies in the career and well when I came my left-wing state
1954 spring of 1954 came back in 66 or 67 something like that and I lived in Chicago and
Evanston and Lincoln Nebraska and Pennsylvania other places you know they kind of stopped your
name and then it was hired by Oregon Health Sciences University recruited by them to fill a certain
role they were looking for and came back and my dad had just retired for your stay so there wasn't
any of that overlap anymore but he was of course very closely involved and you know he had season
tickets so I just picked up going to the football games and you know that sort of thing
but that I wasn't you know a sociatel or you stayed in any direct professional capacity
but it was still part of our lives and then you know I was a lifetime member of the life
memory alumni association the varsio who was kind of kicking in a little bit they were getting
anything's going and then the baseball field project came on Pat Casey put that together and asked
me if I would be on their committee and did was and you know the fundraising committee and we
were successful largely because of the $1 million grant from God's John God's who sold a piece of
property and was going to be a huge tax bill so he decided to do something with it and that got
kicked Pat started and he'd probably been there this wasn't a you know he I don't know how many years
he'd been coaching but I'll bet it was close to 10 by the time a stadium project came along so
you know you think of the baseball project and I think the whole program is a project you know
so different from what it was you know back in the day it's patting over night success you know
it just came in and waved the magic wand and they had but that's not the case at all he started
right from the ground zero and they didn't even charge for baseball games when Jack Wright was
there and even in Pat's early days he could just walk in anytime you know free and but he is a
I think a remarkable person a remarkable developer I think he would have done well and whatever he was
he you know the legendary state that he chose baseball but he had he's a talented person you know
not your normal just your regular everyday coach and he spearheaded this and we meet up here in Portland
and we you know tap people we knew and and there are some major donors that stepped up and
got a built so that was a huge that was a real sea change you know the baseball program to have
that facility it was interesting because prior to that time in Jack Riley and Tencelli and others
might have done something similar but until I wish one of the presidents it was it was after
the bigger probably burn could have been no one was it was after him even yes sir all
research I think it was Paul research right said it would be okay to build a permanent facility on
that location but the University's policy prior that time that always been that this was too valuable
piece of property you know it is right not the center campus but it's right on campus and they
want to put dorms there and things like that well so they they wouldn't permit any kind of
improvement in the facilities nothing until the researchers said okay you do this and then that
opened the door for for Pat to go out and begin to and then John Goss coming along but those two
things came together made it possible to put a permanent facility on that site you know it's
the oldest baseball field in college baseball well it is the oldest or the second oldest I think
there might be some dispute about that but it's one of the two and somebody wandered out there one
day in 1907 and drove a stake in the ground and this will be home played but it's never moved you know
it's it's been a big success I think that was good for Pat good for the program I think it made
a possible recruit and that's everything in baseball and Pat now with his reputation he just
recruits nationally you know he doesn't recruit he just answers phone calls basically
sounding success you know somebody said everything went to their one their first college
world series I mean what was your dad what was your dad feel about that yeah but he'd be proud
nicely he'd be dumbfounded this way would have been because you know considering the facilities
of the attitudes and so on so he's he's out of remarkable remarkable job yeah well the last
thing I want to ask you about is just your thoughts on the current direction of the university things
have changed mightily the last few years and there's a lot of momentum heading in different
directions what do you think of all this well I think Oregon State has got really a lot to be proud of
I think you know the current administration has really been in place long enough
I think it's been there's continuity there there was some you know most of presidents
in state more than four or five years it's that you know they move on to other things but
so I think that continuity has been important and I think they played the funding game very well
you know the technology grants and all this so I don't follow it with a microscope but
I don't think they have the reputation that they deserve I think it's not not really their fault
every every institution has areas of excellence and Oregon State is certainly no exception
but it's not the kind of thing that gets the headlines
so but no I think I think it's a it's a really fine institution I know when my older son went
there and had a great time and so
and they just completed a big fundraising campaign yeah just about a billion dollars billion
yeah one of the better campaigns around the country I guess yeah yeah I think so yeah
so they do a good job I think I think Oregon State the Oregon State can be proud of
Oregon State and I think it's possible to get a good education there I think one of the things
that was kind of a negative when I was there they had virtually nothing in the way of liberal arts
and you can only take two years the only operating liberal arts on the undergrad or the
lower division level and that that closed out a lot of you know it's an age when you really
ought to be looking around at you know other things and the opportunities weren't there and
you had to challenge yourself into one of these technical oriented majors and that wasn't always
a good fit for everybody so I think the fact that they expanded that you know that option is
I think adds a lot to it I think they really made that that returned the corner for them as far as
I was concerned when they developed liberal arts college and the good major and so on well Ralph I
want to thank you for this it's been very interesting and fun and lightning for me well it's been
a real pleasure thank you very much okay